la Conférence des Présidents a décidé
que ces deux textes feraient l'objet
d'une discussion générale
commune dans la discussion générale
commune la parole est donc à Monsieur
Frédéric cuviler secrétaire d'État
chargé des transports de la mer et de la
Pêche monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente monieur les
président de commission messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
c'était le 30 octobre 2012 la SNCF
célébrit ses 75 ans existence et nous
faisions un
constat celui d'un système ferroviaire
en crise tant dans le fonctionnement
entre la SNCF et RFF qu'en terme
financiers un constat aussi exprimé par
nos concitoyens et illustré parfois
dramatiquement par des
accidents je pense notamment puisque
nous sommes à quelques jours du terrible
accident de
brtinie combien nous devons mesurer la
responsabilité qui est la notôtre
lorsque nous parlons de la réforme du
ferroviaire de la nécessité de
modernisation de l'enjeu que le
ferroviaire représente pour notre nation
à l'époque j'annonçais la nécessité
d'une vaste réforme du système
ferroviaire une réforme devant lui
redonner du souffle de la clarté et de
l'efficacité nous avons engagé une très
large concertation de nombreux mois avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes et le
projet de loi fut présenté en Conseil
des ministres ce fut le 16 octobre
dernier il a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale le 24 juin après des échanges
intenses
constructive et une actualité qui
n'était pas moins intense et je sais
combien le débat ici ce fut le cas en
commission mais ce sera le cas en séance
publ sera d'une
réelle richesse d'échanges qui doivent
nous amener à paaufiner améliorer le
texte encore et je souhaite que par ce
débat par nos échanges par
l'amélioration du dispositif voté par
l'Assemblée nationale nous puissions
adresser un message de confiance en le
système ferroviaire
français un espoir en son avenir mais
aussi que nous puissions dessiner
un projet qui soit un projet ambitieux
pour le système ferroviaire français
mais aussi pour nos territoires
ambitieux parce que il exige de la
nation qu'elle s'empare de l'enjeu
ferroviaire qu'elle se réapproprie les
enjeux d'aménagement du territoire je
sais combien vous y êtes sensible et
combien c'est une réalité majeure de ce
qui doit apporter de la cohésion
cohésion sociale des velppement
économique développement industriel sur
nos territoires c'est aussi cela le défi
du ferroviaire c'est aussi cela le
patrimoine ferroviaire national c'est
une réforme qui peut paraître technique
même si elle fut largement vulgarisé ces
dernières semaines mais qu' n est pas
moins une réforme de progrès une réforme
moderne et qui poursuit un certain
nombre d'objectifs 5 le prier objectif
est celui
d'affirmer un secteur et un service
public renforcé mieux piloté avec un
état qui impulse qui agit sous le
contrôle de la nation de ses
représentants qui seront désormais
associés le deuxème jeu objectif est la
mise en place d'un gestionnaire
d'infrastructure unifié et la création
d'un groupe public qui soit un groupe
public industriel intégré la nouvelle
SNCF et qui sera un je un enjeu majeur
et puissant du ferroviaire en Europe et
dans le monde car il y a derrière cette
notion du ferroviaire un véritable enjeu
je le disais une véritable vitrine une
vitrine qui est celle du savoir-faire
industriel ferroviaire français le
troisième objectif est la mise en place
d'un pacte national qui doit assurer à
terme l'équilibre financier du système
ferroviaire je sais là aussi combien
vous y êtes sensible 4è objectif la
nécessité parce que le monde ferroviaire
évolue d'assurer la construction d'un
cadre social commun à l'ensemble des
acteurs du ferroviaire parce que en
effet en maintenant le statut des
cheminau en unifiant la famille cheminot
nous devons aussi avoir présent à
l'esprit que le paysage ferroviaire
évolue qu'il existe désormais plus d'une
dizaine d'opérateurs qui agissent dans
le ferroviaire et qui ne sauraiit pas y
avoir des règles disparates synonyme de
concurrence déloyale et faussé et j'y
reviendrai enfin la nécessité parce que
nous avons un grand groupe intégré de
renforcer le rôle du régulateur et de
garantir l'impartialité dans l'accès du
réseau au réseau je vous propose de
revenir non pas brièvement mais les
débats nous permettront d'approfondir
les propos de de cette discussion
générale sur chacun de ces cinq
objectifs tout d'abord renforcer le
service public c'est une
nécessité il faut redonner du contenu à
la notion même de service public
ferroviaire car je l'indiquais à
l'instant le paysage ferroviaire a
beaucoup évolué le service public ne se
limite pas à la seule mise en œuvre de
convention de service public c'est aussi
et surtout la sécurité la sur
la qualité la continuité du service
public ce sont des attentes de la part
de nos concitoyens et des
usagers il faut aussi faire respecter
par tous les exigences de ce service
public
ferroviaire il faut que nous puissions
favoriser la coordination entre les
différentes autorités organisatrices
l'état bien sûr mais aussi les régions
il nous faut veiller à la qualité de
service à la sécurité à l'efficacité de
tous les acteurs du ferroviaire et pas à
la seule
SNCF il faut redonner une stratégie
ferroviaère à notre pays il faut en
finir avec des décisions qui nous le
savons ont été souvent des décision
d'opportunités qui ont été dicté par une
vision à court terme le projet de loi
crée un certain nombre d'instruments
d'outil pour nous permettre de mettre en
œuvre une cette stratégie
elle illustrera le retour de l'État et
plus largement le retour de la puissance
publique ce sera la fonction du Haut
Comité du ferroviaire qu'est-ce que le
Haut Comité du ferroviaire c'est un lieu
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui et qui
manque qui permet l'association des élus
des régions des entreprises des
organisations syndicales bref de tous
les acteurs qui sont amenés à contribuer
à la structuration à l'orientation de
l'avenir même du système ferroviaire en
effet ça n'est pas à la seule SNCF au
seul groupe SNCF historique certes mais
pour
autant n pas avec ce monopole de
déterminer ce qui est un enjeu pour la
nation toute
entière remettons les enjeux
d'efficacité économique d'équité
territoriale de puissance industrielle
qui sont stratégiques pour le pays au
cœur même des lieux de
décision le Parlement et vous le savez
trop longtemps tenu à pourra ainsi se
saisir s'il le souhaite de ses enjeux
d'avenir le texte le prévoit il nous
faut pouvoir l'amener à prendre position
régulièrement sous forme de surveillance
sur les enjeux financiers sur les enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire sur les
enjeux environnementaux et sociaux du
système ferroviaire l'état
fixera enfin les objectifs du groupe
public SNCF j'y reviendrai mais il le
fera à travers des contrats qui seront
conclus c'est l'État qui dressera les
perspectives et impulsera la
dynamique l'Assemblée nationale a
souhaité renforcer ses aspects je sais
pouvoir compter sur vous mesdames
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
pour contribuer au renforcement de la
nation et de l'État dans cette logique
cet objectif et cet enjeu le deuxème axe
de la réforme consiste en la mise en
place d'un gestionnaire d'infrastructure
unifié et la création d'un groupe public
industriel intégré réunifiant la famille
cheminote c'est un constat qui est fait
par
tous le fait de d'assister une forme
d'atomisation des fonctions d'éclatement
des structures des rôles des missions
aujourd'hui RFF comme la SNCF souffre de
ce manque de
cohésion qui pourtant devrait être le
gage d'efficacité le constat est là le
dialogue existe peu ou n'existe plus
entre ces structures les synergies sont
un recré il est indispensable pour la
France de pouvoir disposer d'un acteur
public majeur sur le plan national mais
aussi au niveau européen et mondial je
vous propose de créer ce groupe public
puissant rassemblant les fonctions en
son sein les fonctions liées à
l'infrastructure d'une part réuni au
sein des SNCF réseau et les mission de
l'exploitation d'autre part rassemblé au
sein de SNCF mobilité il s'agira je le
disais d'un groupe intégré parce que
nous avons besoin que la famille
cheminote poursuiveent les mêmes
objectifs associe ses forces ses
ambitions ses volontés nous voulons en
finir avec ce séparatisme stérile et
souvent très pénalisant l'intégration
permettra de de gagner en efficacité
qu'il s'agisse de l'efficacité technique
de l'efficacité des investissements de
la mutualisation des coût l'impulsion de
la dynamique ferroviaire viendra de
l'établissement public de tête qui
assurera le contrôle le pilotage
stratégique désignera une partie
importante des membres du comité du
conseil d'administration du transporteur
donc de la isncf mobilité et du
gestionnaire d'infrastructure
c'est-à-dire des SNCF réseau ce groupe
public sera contrôlé par l'État ou plus
précisément l'état reprendra la place
qui doit être la sienne dans la
définition d'une stratégie nationale la
SNCF sera dirigée par un directoire
composé du président des SNCF réseau et
du président des SNCF mobilité ces deux
présidents seront nommés par l'État ets
seront placés sous l'autorité d'un
conseil de surveillance et de son
président qui lui-même sera choisi par
l'État parce que l'œuvre ferroviaire est
une œuvre collective chacun doit y avoir
et y trouver sa place bien sûr il doit y
avoir d'autres représentants et ils sont
prévus par les textes que je soumets à
votre approbation représentant des
régions le rôle des régions s'est accru
ces dernières années et de façon
considérable dans la structuration d'une
offre ferroviaire de
proximité mais aussi les salariés et
l'État doit reprendre la main face au
défis qui sont du ferroviaire signal
fort pour l'efficacité économique et
industrielle SNCF réseau c'est-à-dire
gestionnaire d'infrastructure sera enfin
unifié aujourd'hui ce sont les agents de
la
DCF ce sont aussi les agents des SNCF
Infra ou encore les agents des RFF qui
tous sont chargés chacun dans leurs
entités de la gestion de
l'infrastructure ils sont tous séparés
éclatés avec je le
disais une séparation qui invite à ne
pas faire
converger les volontés communes et je
crois pouvoir dire que ils ont même été
opposé or je pense que et vous en
conviendrez ça n'est pas en sép parant
des personnes qui doivent travailler
travailler ensemble ceux qui gèent
l'infrastructure d'une part et ceux qui
l'utilisent que nous pouvons donner les
gage d'une plus grande efficacité c'est
bien le contraire nous devons les
rassembler et là encore l'actualité nous
en a donné une démonstration flagrante
nous y reviendrons dans un débat je le
disais cette entreprise que nous
proposons c'est un groupe unifié qui
permettra de mobiliser toutes les les
énergies et de faciliter aussi et c'est
important les mobilités internes de
faire en sorte que là où nous devons
décider
l'investissement ce soit en cohérence
avec le service et que nous soyons
sensibles au fait que investissement et
utilisation des infrastructure puisse
aller de paire le 3è axe de la réforme
est la conclusion d'un pacte national
pour sauver et assurer financièrement la
pérennité de ce qui est pour nous un
modèle de service public ferroviaire
national aujourd'hui nous en sommes
conscients ce
sontutom prtiquement chaque année plus
d'1,5 milliards d'euros de dettes
nouvelles
générées par le système et même au-delà
si l'on intègre la construction actuelle
de quatre lignes à grande vitesse
financé par
RFF en recourant à
l'impôt
ainsi nous avons face à nous ce
défi un certain nombre d'infrastructures
ont été financé engageant l'avenir même
du ferroviaire
le gouvernement propose dans le projet
de loi de stopper l'alourdissement du
fardeau de la dette et pour cela un
certain nombre de dispositions
nécessiteront la contribution de tous et
l'engagement de la nation tout d'abord
il convient de cesser de faire financer
les grands travaux par RFF de le faire
par emprunt sans que nous ne soyons à
même de savoir si ceux-ci pourront être
remboursés par
RFF ces dernières années c'est un
constat
RFF a été soumise à l'exence de l'État
l'État s'est déchargé sur RFF pour
financer les LGV quelle en est la
conséquence de moindre financement pour
l'entretien et la modernisation de nos
lignes de train du quotidien et vous en
êtes tous
les témoins chacun sur vos territoires
m'interpeller
pour m'indiquer combien telle ou telle
nécessité de remise à niveau et le
constat qui m'accueillait lors de ma
nomination il y a plus de 2 ans qui
était celui de l'École polytechnique de
Lausanne sur le niveau de dégradation du
réseau ferroviaire en était un constat
supplémentaire nous devons assurer le
maintien au niveau la modernisation le
renouvellement et pour cela il ne
saurait être question
de passer cette réalité au second plan
parce qu'il s'agit du patrimoine
national parce qu'il s'agit de ce qui
doit être préservé ce qui doit être
développé mais aussi
modernisé nous avons résolument par ce
texte
souhaité mettre un terme à cette
politique la course en avant qui s'est
affranchie de toute obligation de
financement qui a laissé porter aux
générations futures une dette qui
aujourd'hui est lesté de plus de 40
milliards depuis 2 ans j'ai tenu sous
l'autorité des premiers ministres
Jean-Marc hraud et manuel Vals à
redéfinir clairement les priorités en
matière de politique de transport
priorité a été donné au transport du
quotidien citons deux exemples tout
d'abord le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport avec le
célèbre rapport Duron et la mise en
place qui nous concerne prioritairement
d'un plan ambitieux de modernisation du
réseau ferroviaire mais ce plan de
modernisation n'a de sens que si nous
avons un regard qui est un regard
d'ensemble que si nous restructurons le
système ferroviaire que si nous avons
souci de l'efficacité économique que
nous avons le souci de mettre en place
une véritable stratégie d'investissement
de l'ensemble du
système nous devons également optimiser
le savoir-faire la capacité la
compétence nous devons faire en sorte
que cette ingénierie cette capacité
qu'il s'agisse de la maîtrise d'ouvrage
de la maîtrise d'œuvre des agents RFF de
la SNCF soit réunis coordonné optimisé
et donne enfin la fierté retrouvée à la
famille cheminote deuxème disposition
l'état prendra part à cet effort
financier imaginez pour ceux qui ne le
savent pas car ça n'est pas vulgarisé
que l'État reçoit aujourd'hui des
dividendes sur le ferroviaire alors même
que le ferroviaire est endetté à plus de
40 milliards d'euros il faut donc
remettre de la logique il faut donc être
responsable et nous proposons donc le
reversement des dividendes du
transporteur vers le gestionnaire
d'infrastructure et nous proposons
également la compensation fiscale au
sein du groupe des excédents et des
déficits le Transporteur et le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure ainsi
participeront à cet effort par des
mesures d'optimisation d'efficacité de
meilleure organisation du
travail enfin nous vous proposerons une
règle une règle qui soit celle du
rétablissement des équilibres financiers
qui fasse l'objet d'un contrat avec
l'État ce pacte national n'a pas pour
objectif ni pour effet comme je l'ai
entendu ces dernières semaines de
dégrader les conditions de travail
dégrader les niveaux de rémunération des
chemineaux en particulier ne remet pas
en cause le statut des cheminaux cela a
été une contrevérité véhiculée à des
fins de mobilisation il a au contraire
pour ambition de préserver de renforcer
et développer le service ferroviaire
français le projet de loi donne ainsi
les instruments aux futur groupes pour
stabiliser en 10 an son endettement cet
effort est un effort indispensable il ne
règle pas le fardeau de la dette
historique j'en conviens l'État n'a pas
aujourd'hui et vous le savez les moyens
de reprendre une partie de cette dette
d'ailleurs c'est une question de méthode
il ne y aurait aucun sens à reprendre
une partie de la dette sans avoir
préalablement remis le système dans une
logique vertueuse c'est précisément ce
que propose ce projet de loi il prévoit
donc que le gouvernement remette au
Parlement un rapport sur les moyens pour
traiter la question de l'évolution de la
dette historique monsieur le rapporteur
cher michel Teston je sais que vous êtes
sensible à cette question vous avait
souhaité d'ailleurs en commission aller
plus loin et je salue cette position 4è
axe de la réforme le volet social que
n'aije entendu là encore ces dernières
semaines j'ai conscience des inquiétudes
elles ont été exprimé parfois même
véhiculé utilisé mais certains ont fait
dire au projet de loi ce qu'il ne
disaient pas et cette nouvelle lecture
me permettra d'y revenir et d'en faire
démonstration devant
vous ces inquiétudes je ne les ignore
pas et précisément c'est parce qu'elles
existent que nous souhaitons apporter
réponse la France ne peut sans
conséquence s'engager dans une bataille
sociale du rail et depuis 2 ans c'est
cet esprit de dialogue qui s'est imposé
avec la volonté de travailler avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
avec les groupes parlementaires vous en
avez été les acteurs les témoins c'est
ce souci du dialogue social qui a animé
mon travail celui de mon équipe avec
pour seul objectif de faire réussir le
ferroviaire français du
quotidien je souhaite affirmer avec
force ma conviction
et ma méthode celle de l'importance du
dialogue social pour accompagner les
changements ils sont indispensables
changements dont la SNCF a besoin tout
le monde en est conscient les usagers
les premiers mais les acteurs eux-mêmes
en sont
quotidiennement conscients et et là
encore nous témoigne de la nécessité de
réforme
je souhaite d'ailleurs je le dis avec
beaucoup là aussi de conviction mais
aussi de solennité je souhaite saluer
l'esprit de
responsabilité je souhaite remercier les
organisations syndicale
représentative qui ont souhaité
s'engager en signant les accords de
modernisation le 13 juin
dernier ces accords de modernisation
vous voyez vous vous trompez monsieur le
ministre
permettez-moi de répondre à votre
interpellation il est des syndicats qui
s'engagent qui signent qui négocient et
qui permettent d'éviter des conflits
sociaux qui peuvent en effet être
préjudiciables aux usagers je salue donc
cet esprit de responsabilité je suis
persuadé que vous n'aviez pas bien
entendu le sens de ma formule sinon vous
auriez approuvé mes propos les accords
qui ont été signés sont des accords qui
se sont traduits par des avancées
t ont été d'ailleurs acté adopté
amélioré à l'Assemblée nationale
notamment pour ce qui concerne les
termes d'intégration sociale du futur
groupe le groupe disposera d'instances
représentatives du personnel centralisé
de délégués syndicaux centrux
portant la négociation sociale au niveau
transversal cette intégration se fera
aussi par la gestion des réformes des
ressources humaines qui sera piloté au
niveau de l'épique de tête
avec et c'est important la gestion
coordonnée des parcours et de la
mobilité au sein même de cette grande
entreprise de ce grand groupe public il
s'agit tout simplement de donner
concrétisation à mes propos et à notre
volonté c'est-à-dire de permettre à
chaque chemineau par la mobilité sociale
par un parcours professionnel d'avoir
des perspectives de progression de
changer de métier de changer de
formation de pouvoir apporter mais aussi
apprendre de donner des perspective
nouvelle à sa carrière de pouvoir faire
en sorte que la découverte d'autres
métiers soit un signe de modernisation
de progression de progression
individuelle et professionnelle cela
sera garanti par ce texte il s'agit
d'accompagner l'ambition
collective celle du futur groupe public
SNCF mais aussi les aspiration légitime
de chacun de ses salariés le volet
social est important car c l'avenir du
service public et cet avenir du service
public ne peut se faire sans qu'il
existe un cadre social commun à
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
ferroviaire vous le savez depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années le
ferroviaire est désormais pour ce qui
est de sa partie frite ouverte à la
concurrence pourtant ceux qui ont été
les promoteurs de cette ouverture à la
concurrence n'ont pas pris un certain
nombre de précautions qui désormais
déstabilise le secteur ferroviaire fret
je pense notamment à des précautions
permettant d'éviter la mise en place
d'une concurrence qui ne soit pas faussé
d'éviter qu'il y ait des règles
disparates qui s'appliquent à chacun des
acteurs il faut donc qu'il y ait des
règles sociales qui soient des règles
sociales communes qui ne laissent pas la
charge au secteur public et les profits
au secteur
privé ces erreurs qui ont été commises
lors de la libéralisation du fret je
souhaite qu'elles ne soit pas reproduite
d'abord parce qu'un calendrier européen
se présentera à nous et nous y
reviendrons que pour défendre un service
public encore faut-il le moderniser et
le préparer à ces rendez-vous qui
conditionneront son existence et son
avenir et que l'on ne peut pas laisser
la libre concurrence s'exercer sans même
qu'il y ait un minimum de règles qui
s'aos à tous c'est ainsi que nous
pourrons avoir une véritable politique
publique ferroviaire respectueuse des
enjeux je le disais de sécurité
d'aménagement du territoire mais aussi
d'une vision qui doit être une vision
partagée industrielle et de
développement économique par ailleurs je
n'ai pas souhaité et là encore je
répondrai certainement à des
interrogations qui ne manqueront pas de
d'être posé je n'ai pas souhaité et je
l'ai dit dès les premiers jour de ma
prise de de fonction
devancer une mise en
concurrence sans que nous n'ayons
préalablement permis à l'entreprise
nationale d'être efficace d'être
compétitive ne pas laisser l'ouverture
du marché sans qu'un certain nombre de
gardefous s'applique à chacun c'est ma
méthode
notamment la raison pour laquelle ce
projet de loi aujourd'hui n'a pas
souhaité anticiper des dates d'ailleurs
fort incertaines pu puisque lorsque là
encore je prenais mes premières
fonctions ministre des Transports il
m'était indiqué un calendrier européen
opposable alors même que celui-ci ne
l'était pas preuv enné nous n'avons
toujours pas de façon certaine les dates
de l'ensemble de la libéralisation du
secteur et que par ailleurs c'était ne
pas penser à peut-être d'autres périodes
ont illustré l'absence de vigilance de
l'état du gouvernement de la France au
niveau européen mais que désor nous
sommes dans l'exigence et que lorsque
nous engageons des négociations au
niveau européen des discussions avec le
commissaire européens ça n'est pas pour
reculer mais c'est bien pour au
contraire faire triompher une vision qui
est la nôtre et ne pas anticiper des
réformes qui nous seraient imposer sans
même que nous fassions valoir un certain
nombre des principes qui sont ceux que
j'expose devant vous ainsi contrairement
à un certain nombre d'esprits pétris du
dogme libéral je n'ai pas souhaité anti
iciper des échéances et je souhaite
encore les négocier pied à pied au
niveau
européen je veux des règles qui soient
protectrices et qui soient appliqué à
tous nous devons donc proposer de
construire un cadre social qui soit un
cadre social commun personne ne dit
jamais autre chose lorsqu'il s'agit de
la concurrence la concurrence elle doit
se faire à règle égale pour chacun des
acteurs européen
l'occasion de sacrifier ce qui
représente l'enjeu de l'équilibre des
territoires et qui serait sacrifié au
profit de logique purement
financière la la bataille du rail elle
est désormais économique elle se joue et
vous le savez au niveau européen le
projet de loi et je le dis et je
l'assume une réelle avancée contre un
certain nombre de véléités je les
entends à chacun des conseils des
ministres européens mais pas d'ailleurs
parfois dans le cadre
interne des volontés contre un certain
nombre de vééité d'une concurrence
déchaîné non ce projet de loi au
contraire souhaite apporter une forme de
protection de renforcement de mettre en
place l'armature d'un édifice public
sécurisé prêt à affronter l'avenir non
pas se tourner vers le passé y être
nostalgique mais au contraire assurer la
modernisation du ferroviaire dernier
point
nous aurons à
assurer que le cadre de la régulation
s'applique et quelques mots avant que
nous y venions y compris sur des
amendements qui ne manquont pas d'être
déposés et débattus grâce à un
régulateur extérieur puisque lorsque
nous souhaitons la puissance d'un groupe
public intégré il faut que nous
puissions avoir un régulateur qui
répondre là pour le coup à un certain
nombre de garanties d'accès au réseau
l'accès au réseau dans des conditions
transparentes le régulateur aura un rôle
central dans ce nouveau dispositif il
devra veiller à ce que le système ne
dérive pas et il sera attentif ce seront
ses compétences à ce que la réalité
financière soit et la stratégie la
directive financière soit
scrupuleusement maintenue je suis aussi
attaché à son indépendance c'est
pourquoi par exemple j'ai soutenu cé é à
l'Assemblée nationale des initiatives
visant à avoir un avis conforme de la
RAF non seulement pour le péage mais
aussi pour les redevances gar
l'existence d'un régulateur fort est une
contrepartie je le disais nécessaire un
groupe ferrovire fort pour terminer mes
propos je tiens à dire
ici que je sais le rôle qui est le mien
dans la responsabilité de ce
débat la responsabilité qui est celle
que j'ai devant vous qui est à la fois
la nécessité et je l'ai fait de défendre
un héritage commun qui est l'héritage
humain aussi d'une histoire du
ferroviaire qui est intimement lié avec
le patrimoine de notre nation sa réalité
ses territoires mais aussi la nécessité
qui est la nôtre
en évoquant et en abordant ce texte de
permettre
que cette histoire ne soit pas une
histoire du passé mais qu'elle puisse au
contraire se poursuivre et s'amplifier
il y a dans notre histoire une
symbolique qui est très forte du
ferroviaire il y a dans notre pays une
réalité qui est très forte de cette
structuration du pays grâce au
ferroviaires c'est celle de l'image du
progrès qui a été initié notamment
première partie du 19e siècle mais nous
ne sommes plus à ces périodes de
fondation nous sommes peut-être un
nouveau tournant pour le ferroviaire une
forme de refondation nous devons aborder
un contexte qui est un contexte européen
voire mondialisé nous avons la réalité
de l'industrie ferroviaire française qui
est une grande richesse et que nous
soutenons et pour lequel nous devons
avoir une vision l'état stratège de
soutien d'impulsion imaginer tout de
même mais là aussi les débats qui
seront là encore enrichi de vos
expériences que lorsque nous parlons des
lignes nationales lorsque nous parlons
des trains d'équilibre du territoire
nous nous sommes confrontés à une
réalité c'est que d'un point de vue
industriel il n'existe il n'existait pas
de train susceptible de remplir ses
missions pour le remplacement des
corailes les fameuses Intercités et que
l'industrie ferroviaire elle-même
n'avait pas anticipé ce que pouvait être
une vision stratégique de l'organisation
des réseaux de la complémentarité entre
le train régional le train national et
la grande vitesse il fallait bien qu'il
y ait donc une impulsion nous donnons
les lieu de cette impulsion et je
remercie Arnaud Montebourg d'ailleurs
d'avoir à mes côtés présidé à plusieurs
reprises le comité stratégique
ferroviaire d'avoir donné des budgets
nécessaires Monsieur Louis ngre ne
pourra pas méconnaître cette réalité ne
pourra pas nous priver des discours dans
d'autres responsabilités qui sont les
siennes qui souvent mettent en exerg
l'action du gouvernement dans ce domaine
ferroviaire ne pourra pas vous priver de
ce satisfacite parfois nous ne sommes
pas parfaits nous pouvons encore
progresser mais V que pour la première
fois nous avons une véritable impulsion
donnée preuve enné la volonté exprimée
par le Premier ministre Jean-Marc Erraud
qui a été confirmé par Manuel vas de
pouvoir pour la première fois depuis 30
ans voter et commander les financements
de renouvellement à perspective de 2025
de l'ensemble des trains d'équilibre du
territoire 30 ans qu'il n'y avait pas eu
la moindre commande le moindre
renouvellement de matériel roulant et le
tout en pleine discussion cohésion avec
les acteurs économiques lorsque nous
lançons les autoroutes ferroviaires
dois-je parler là aussi de la stratégie
qui est la nôtre de pouvoir accompagner
les enjeux industriels des territoires
autour de ces grandes autoroutes
ferroviaires nous sauvons l'industrie du
ferroviaire et j'aurai l'occasion dans
les tout prochains jours d'aller visiter
les industries lor qui là encore étaient
pleinement dépendant de la commande
publique nous l'avons honoré nous avons
impulsé une démarche nouvelle nous avons
sauvé l'emploi et nous avons mis un fond
qui est un fond dédié au ferroviaires
permettant sur le modèle de
l'aéronautique de faire en sorte que les
grands acteurs puissent accompagner les
PME les ETI et de pouvoir cléer en
quelque sorte un able cluster des
activités ferroviaires nous sommes des
leaders mondiaux c'est vrai des
infrastructures c'est vrai des cœurs de
voie c'est vrai du matériel roulant nous
avons encore il y a quelques jours des
grands marchés qui sont des marchés
ferroviaires urbains ou non qui ont été
à l'étranger gagné par les opérateurs
français nous devons donc nous-même
poursuivre impulser donner une chance
supplémentaire faire en sorte que nous
soyons et nous mettions le système
ferroviaire non pas hors de son temps
comme j'ai pu l'entendre parfois où j'ai
peut-être eu à le regretter de la part
d'un certain nombre de positions mais au
contraire de le placer face à des défis
qui sont des défis d'avenir de faire
avec conviction avec respect par rapport
à tous ceux qui ont la compétence et qui
mettent à la disposition de cette
industrie et de ses
acteurs nous ne sommes pas favorables
nous l'avons démontré et nous avons
gagné cette discussion européenne alors
même que d'autres nous
mettaient en prévention sur d'éventuels
euroincompatibilités de textes qui
eux-mêmes n'étaient pas opposables à la
volonté de la France nous avons à peser
de tout notre poids au niveau européen
nous avons à faire dominer ce qui est
notre vision du ferroviaire c'est notre
responsabilité comme grande nation
ferroviaire européenne nous nous sommes
opposés à un modèle modèle unique avec
des règles uniques souvent
destructrices nous avons souhaité au
contraire que nous n'ayons pas à nous
affranchir de la réalité du patrimoine
même ferroviaire que nous puissions
conjuguer compétitivité réalité
économique filière industrielles et que
nous ayons notre capacité au niveau
européen à organiser la gouvernance même
du système ferroviaire là où d'autres
essayer de nous imposer un système
d'organisation unique et bien la France
qui pendant trop longtemps a été absente
de ces enjeux ces dernières années je
crois pouvoir le dire a retrouvé sa
place au niveau européen dans les
discussions européennes encore
fallait-il qu'elle l'occupe qu'elle soit
présente et qu'elle soit exigeante
encore fallait-il qu'elle sache nouer
les alliances nécessaires avec les
grandes nations ferroviaires je pense à
nos amis allemands avec lesquels nous
avons réussi à travailler sur la vision
qui est la nôtre des différents paquets
ferroviaires et de l'organisation de la
gouvernance européenne et nous avons
fait reculer ce qui devait s'imposer à
l'Europe du ferroviaire une vision
unique qui était celle d'un libéralisme
que j'ai qualifié tout à l'heure voilà
le message que je souhaite vous adresser
voilà le message que je souhaite porter
devant vous devant les représentants de
la nation je souhaite en eff fait que
nous puissions refonder le système
ferroviaire redonner force et vigueur
redonner vertu mais aussi confiance en
le service publics nous devons
aujourd'hui tracer des perspectives qui
sont celles de progrès et donner à la
France le maillage nécessaire tant
industriel économique mais aussi humain
de ce que le service public peut
apporter à chacun de nos territoires
voilà l'enjeu de ce projet de réforme
ferroviaire
je sais qu'il va nous occuper de longues
heures de longues journées dans un
climat que je souhaite parce qu'il est
apaisé le débat et le dialogue social l'
emporté c'est ce qui est pour moi la
priorité le dialogue social est celui
qui a permis de faire prendre conscience
de ce que l'avenir du ferroviaire
méritait d'une mobilisation commune avec
une volé de modernisation mais aussi des
réponses aux attentes de nos concitoyens
je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur michel
Teston rapporteur de la commission du
développement
durable monsieur le sénateur vous avez
la
parole madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission du développement durable
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des finances chers et chers collègues la
réforme ferroviaire est nécessaire et
urgente elle assure la cohérence du
système ferroviaire tout en étant
eurocompatible comment en effet ne pas
replacer cette réforme dans son contexte
européen les discussions sont en cours
autour d'un 4e paquet ferroviaire avec
de nouvelles étapes d'ouverture à la
concurrence
ce projet de loi n'a pas pour objet
d'anticiper ces étapes qu'à titre
personnel je n'appelle pas forcément de
mes vux ceci étant nous devons nous
préparer à cette échéance faute de quoi
lancf risque de connaître les mêmes
déconvenus que sa filiale fr SNCF lors
de la libéralisation du fret pour cela
nous devons faire disparaître les trois
handicaps dont souffre notre système
ferroviaire premier handicap la
séparation de la gestion de
l'infrastructure entre deux entités RFF
et la SNCF ainsi que l'a prévu la loi de
1997 cette séparation inédite dans le
monde n'est aujourd'hui plus défendue
par personne comme l'ont montré les
conclusions des assise du ferroviaire
organisé à l'automne 2011 elle a été à
l'origine de nombreux dysfonctionnement
dans l'entretien du réseau surcout de
gestion manque de réactivité d'ilution
des responsabilités et cetera deè
handicap une dette
colossale pèse sur notre système
ferroviaire elle atteint aujourd'hui 44
milliards d'euros au total dont 37
milliards pour RFF la réforme de
1997 a laissé ce problème sans solution
puisque RFF a été considéré dès le
départ comme une structure de défaisance
de la dette l'État qui cherchait à
maîtriser son endettement pour
satisfaire aux critères de mastrich
n'avait pas souhaité reprendre une
partie de la dette de la SNCF
contrairement à ce qui avait été fait en
Allemagne quelques années auparavant
pour la deutscheban réseau feré lefan
s'est donc retrouvé avec plus de 20
milliards d'euros de dett issu de la
SNCF sans qu'aucune mesure structurelle
n'ait été prise pour réduire sa
progression
par la suite la double dérive des coûts
de gestion du réseau existant et de
développement des lignes nouvelles a
conduit à l'emballement de la dette que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui si l'on ne
fait rien la dette du réseau pourrait
atteindre près de 70 milliards d'euros
en 2025 cette situation n'est pas
soutenable 3è handicap notre système
ferroviaire a souffert d'une
insuffisante préparation à l'ouverture à
la concurrence du fret ferrov
en l'absence d'un cadre social homogène
cette impréparation a conduit à un
rapide effondrement de l'activité de
frncf ces handicaps ont été d'autant
plus dommageables que l'État n'a pas su
ou pas pu jouer le rôle d'arbitre qui
aurait dû être le sien dans les conflits
entre RFF et la SNCF il s'est peu
impliqué dans les questions stratégiques
laissant ainsi d'importantes marges de
manœuvre aux deux établissements
ces éléments de contexte doivent suffire
à démontrer l'absolue nécessité de cette
réforme et l'urgence qu'il y a à agir ce
projet de loi apporte des réponses
concrètes aux difficultés que je viens
d'évoquer il marque le retour de l'État
stratège il crée un gestionnaire
d'infrastructure unifié SNCF réseau qui
rassemble en son sein les activités
aujourd'hui exercé par RFF la DCF et
SNCF inf Frat il insèt le gestionnaire
d'infrastructure SNCF réseau et
l'exploitant l'exploitant pardon des
services de transport ferroviaire SNCF
mobilité dans un même groupe public
ferroviaire la SNCF dans le jargon
européen on parle d'une structure
verticalement intégrée il s'agit en
quelque sorte de mettre en place une
holding ferroviaire à la française tout
en conservant le statut d'pque de ces
différentes composantes l'expérience
passée et la réalité du terrain ont en
effet montré que seul un système intégré
pouvait être réellement efficace pour un
fonctionnement optimal du réseau les
problématiques d'entretien du réseau et
les contraintes d'exploitation ne
peuvent pas être systématiquement
dissociées c'est d'ailleurs une
organisation similaire qu'a choisi
laadit Cheman ce modèle intégré qui a
pourtant fait ses preuves n'a pas eu
dans les premiers temps monsieur le
ministre l'a rappelé les faveurs de la
Commission européenne qui voulait aller
jusqu'à l'interdire fort heureusement
vous avez su monsieur le ministre
démontrer qu'il s'agissait d'un modèle
pertinent face au modèle opposé d'une
séparation intégrale entre la gestion de
l'infrastructure d'une part et
l'exploitation des services de transport
d'autre part et bien il nous revient
désormais d'appuyer la position que vous
avez prise en adoptant ce texte en
parallèle cette intégration ce texte
offre aux concurrents de la SNCF de
réelles garanties d'indépendance dans
l'exercice des fonctions dites essentiel
à savoir la tarification et laallocation
des sillons en conformité avec le droit
européen existant
l'ARAF dont le rôle a été
considérablement renforcé surtout après
l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale contrôlera le respect de ces
exigences ce texte comporte également
des mesures fortes
destiné à mettre fin à la dérive
financière du système le pilotage du
système ferroviaire sera renforcé
puisque le projet de loi organise le
retour de l'État stratège et met en
place des outils destinés à maîtriser
l'endettement du système les contrats
signés entre l'État et les différents
épiques du groupe ainsi qu'une règle de
maîtrise de l'endettement don
l'application sera surveillée par la RAF
l'autorité se voit ainsi doté d'un
nouveau
qu'on pourrait qualifier de régulateur
économique du système enfin ce projet de
loi pose les bases d'un cadre social
commun à l'ensemble des salariés de la
branche ferroviaire qui sera élaboré
pour l'essentiel par les partenaires
sociaux mais sur la base d'un décret
socle l'Assemblée nationale a
substantiellement et utilement complété
ce projet de loi sous l'impulsion de son
rapporteur Gill Savari dont je voudrais
souligner
devant vous la compétence et
l'engagement la commission du
développement durable du Sénat a de son
côté préserver les équilibres atteint à
l'Assemblée nationale tout en complétant
le texte sur plusieurs points à
l'article 1er les députés ont largement
pris en compte les aspirations des
cheminau en renforçant l'intégration du
Group public ferroviaire ce travail
important a été salué par la commission
du développement durable du Sénat il est
essentiel que nous conservions les gages
obtenus en terme de réunification de la
famille
cheminot les députés ont aussi compléter
les dispositions du texte relative à la
gouvernance en ajoutant au comité du
système de transport ferroviaire un
comité des opérateur du réseau composé
des clients de SNCF réseau dans ce
domaine notre commission a prévu la
participation des associations de
protection de l'environnement agréé au
au comité du système de transport FERR
elle a aussi prévu à l'article 2 que le
Haut Comité délibère annuellement sur
des recommandations d'action et les
propositions dévolution du contrat signé
entre SNCF réseau et l'État notre
commission a salué les différentes
mesures visant à renforcer l'information
et le contrôle du Parlement sur le
système de transport ferroviaire tel que
la transmission systématique au
Parlement des projets de contrat signés
entre l'État et les établissements du
Grou public ferroviaire ou la mise en
place d'un schéma national des services
de transport nous y avons ajouté la
présence d'un député et d'un sénateur au
conseil de surveillance de la SNCF à
l'article 2 l'Assemblée nationale a
précisé la règle de maîtrise de
l'endettement du réseau en distinguant
d'une part les investissements liés à la
maintenance du réseau c'est-à-dire les
investissements de renouvellement
d'autre part les investissements de
développement du réseau notre commission
a adopté plusieurs amendements de
clarification rédactionnelle dont deux
importants présentés par François patria
au nom de la commission des finances au
même article 2 notre commission a adopté
un amendement identifiant SNCF réseau
comme le propriétaire unique de
l'ensemble des lignes du réseau ferré
national il nous a semblé nécessaire
d'écarter toute perspective de
démantelllement du réseau ferré national
même si certaines délégations
strictement encadrées sont possibles
dans le même dans le même esprit nous
avons accepté les articles de B a et de
b b qui ouvr la possibilité aux régions
de racheter certaines petites lignes
d'intérêt purement local afin de ne pas
les laisser se détériorer et qui
permettent aux régions de créer ou
d'exploiter des lignes d'intérêt
régional sont aussi réglés certains cas
ponctuels comme CELI de la ligne digne
Nice dont la région PACA pourra devenir
gestionnaire de pleine compétenence
comme le précédent cet article ne remet
pas en cause l'unicité du réseau
national puisque seul des
infrastructures d'intérêt local sont
visées l'article 2 ter prévoit la remise
d'un rapport du Gouvernement au
Parlement sur les solutions à mettre en
œuvre pour traiter de l'évolution de la
dette historique du système ferrovia
notre commission a souhaité inclure
explicitement dans ce rapport l'examen
du une reprise par l'état de tout tout
parti de la dette de SNCF réseau le
portage par SNCF Réau d'une dette qu'il
ne peut amortir et dont l'état est de
facto le garant n'est en effet pas
légitime cette dette représente chacuné
des charges financières considérables
qui gagneraiit à être investi dans
l'entretien et la régénération du réseau
à l'article 4 les pouvoirs de la RAF ont
été est sensiblement étendu par
l'Assemblée nationale son avis conforme
sur les redevances d'infrastructures a
été rétablie et étendu aux redevances
des gares et relativ à l'accès aux
infrastructures de services l'autorité
sera en outre chargé de veiller à ce que
les décisions de la SNCF respectent
l'indépendance de SNCF réseau dans
l'exercice des fonctions
essentielles nous n'avons pas modifié
les dispositions relatives au collège de
de l'ARAF qui conservera SEP membres
comme aujourd'hui trois d'entre eux le
président et les deux vice-présidents
nommés par les présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale du Sénat exerçant leur
fonction à temps plein notre commission
du développement durable a par ailleurs
inscrit dans la loi le principe de la
publicité de l'ensemble des propositions
avis et décisions de l'ARAF en
conformité avec la directive 2012 34 de
l'Union européenne établissant un espace
ferroviaire unique européen à l'article
5 qui traite de SNCF
mobilité les députés ont notamment prévu
une décomposition par ligne le compte
TER en commission nous avons précisé que
cette décomposition sera définie pour
chaque région et non dans le cadre d'un
référentiel commun nous avons aussi
précisé que le transport ferroviaire de
marchandises doit figurer au nombre des
objectifs assignés à SNCF mobilité dans
le cadre de son contrat décennel avec
l'État afin de mieux prendre en compte
la situation très préoccupante du fret
de ferroviaire l'article 5 bis constitue
un apport important de nos collègues
députés il répond à un certain nombre de
revendications phares des région en leur
confiant un rôle de chef de file en
matière d'aménagement desgardes
d'intérêt régional en leur octroyant la
liberté tarifaire sous réserve du
maintien des tarifs sociaux nationaux en
permettant de leur transférer la propre
propriété du matériel roulant et en
imposant une présentation comptable
séparée des contrats de servicees TER
l'équilibre trouvé sur ces points
correspond à une solution de compromis
que nous souhaitions également et nous a
semblé judicieux de l'accepter en l'état
nous avons toutefois souhaité assurer
l'effectivité de ces dispositions en
introduisant à l'article 5 TER une
ressource fiscale dédiée au financement
de la compétence transport des régions
on observe en effet un décalage
croissant entre les compétences confié
aux régions qui s'accroissent au fur et
à mesure des réformes et leurs
ressources propres qui diminue fortement
depuis la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle l'option retenue par la
commission est celle proposée par
Jean-Jacques filleul et Roland ris
notamment d'un versement de transport
interstitiel et qui ne concerne que les
territoires situés hors périmètre de
transport urbain les PTU et plafonné à
055 % de la masse salariale alors mes
chers et chers collègues il n'existe pas
de solution parfaite en la matière mais
celle que nous avons retenue nous a
semblé moins pénalisante pour la
compétitivité des entreprises que celle
d'un versement de transport additionnel
qui viendrait s'ajouter au au 2 % déjà
acquité dans la plupart des grandes
agglomérations nous avons également
introduit un nouvel article 6 bis A qui
prévoit la mise en place d'une
protection spécifique des circulations
ferroviair contre les effets
perturbateurs des ondes émises par les
installations radioélectriques TICE ce
problème déjà évoqué par Gill Savari
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas pu être
traité dans le cadre de la propulion de
loi relative à l'exposition aux zones
électromagnétiques et il est donc
important de le régler ici autre point
important le volet sécurité et sreté
ferroviaire l'article 6 ter a impose une
remontée à l'établissement public de
sécurité ferroviaire le PSF des
événements mettant en cause la sécurité
ferroviaire et prévoi un mécanisme de
sanction en cas de manquement à cette
obligation je suis favorable à cette
mesure qui préfigure l'instauration
d'une culture du compte-rendu
contte-rendu des forts enjeux de la
sécurité
ferroviaire après le terrible accident
de brtinie sur Orge il convient
d'afficher la mobilisation de l'ensemble
des acteurs du système ferroviaire dans
ce domaine l'article 6
pose le principe de libre accès des
forces de l'ordre au véhicules
ferroviaires pour l'exercice de leur
mission de protection de l'ordre
publique et la sortie d'une sanction
pénale cette mesure vise à faciliter la
présence policière à bord des trains
nationaux comme étranger à l'article 7
qui rattache la surveillance générale la
SUGE de la SNCF à l'pic de tête les
députés ont fait en sorte que la
mobilisation de la SUGE soit
systématique pour l'ensemble des opér
opateur dès lors que les tarifs associés
à ces prestations sont transparents non
discriminatoires et contrôlés par un
avis conforme de l'ARF cette solution me
paraît efficiente et de bon sens
l'article 9 bis a été introduit par la
commission du développement durable de
l'Assemblée nationale en coordination
avec le dépôt de la proposition de
organique relative à la nomination des
dirigeants de la SNCF il s'agit de
prévoir l'audition des deux membres du
directoire et du président du conseil de
surveillance de la SNCF devant les
commissions compétentes du Parlement aux
articles 10 11 et 16 les députés ont
considérablement clarifié et sécurisé
les opérations de transfert de propriété
entre les trois épiques à la fois sur
les aspects juridiques comptable et
fiscaux un travail technique que nous
avons encore amélioré en
commission la question de la gestion des
gardes voyageurs a été soulevée par
plusieurs d'entre vous les députés ont
prévu la remise au Parlement d'un
rapport du Gouvernement sur le sujet qui
devra présenter l'impact d'un transfert
des gar à SNC à Fréau ou à des autorités
organisatrices de transport je suis
favorable à cette clause de revoyure
dans la mesure où il n'est pas possible
de traiter de façon satisfaisante dès
aujourd'hui ce sujet éminemment complexe
quant à l'article 11 bis il transfert à
SNCF réseau les terminaux de
marchandises appartenant à l'État et
géré par SNCF mobilité ainsi que
certaines
installations de service autres que les
gardes voyageurs et les centres
d'entretien en commission nous avons
adopter une solution de compromis en ce
qui concerne la liste de références
servant de base au transfert en cas des
acccord le transfert sera
automatiquement constaté par la par le
ministre sur la base de la référence
2013 ce qui correspond à 399 cours frit
au lieu de la référence 2015
c'est-à-dire 171 notre principal souci a
été d'assurer la pérennité du patrimoine
ferroviaire il s'agit en effet d'éviter
toute reconversion prématurée de biens
potentiellement stratégique ou qui
pourrait servir à d'autres opérateurs
ferroviaires enfin nous avons approuvé à
l'article 6 l'ouverture aux salariés de
RFF qui remplissait les conditions
d'embauche au statut lors de le
recrutement un droit d'opté pour le
statut des cheminaux à l'article 14 le
report au 1er juillet 2016 de l'échéance
du 1er juillet 2015 pour l'aboutissement
de la convention collective afin de
laisser davantage de temps aux
partenaires sociaux enfin l'organisation
dans un délai d'un an à compter de la
constitution du groupe public
ferroviaire d'élections professionnelles
anticipé au total la commission du
développement durable a estimé que le
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire
fournit des outils pertinents pour
forcer le système ferroviaire et assurer
son avenir nous avons donc adopté ce
texte ainsi d'ailleurs que la
proposition de loi relative à la
nomination des dirigeants de la SNCF
chers et chers collègues je souhaite
ardemment que notre assemblée puisse
elle aussi manifester largement son
soutien à cette réforme je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
François patriard rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des finances monsieur
le sénateur vous avez la
parole madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Michel chers
collègues évident qu'après
l'excellent rapport de michel Teston je
me contenterai de de parler de ce qui a
impacté notre commission des finances
qui s'est saisi pour avis du projet de
loi portant réforme ferroviaire compte
tenu notamment de l'endettement
préoccupant du système ferroviaire qui
atteint on l'a déjà dit plus de 44
milliards d'euros dont 37 milliards
d'euros au titre de l'infrastructure
cette dette mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre l'INC a reconnu récemment
est en partie une dette publique nous
avons donc le devoir de la maîtriser de
la stabiliser et à terme de la réduire
c'est un un des Gux de ce projet de loi
un parmi quelques autres et non moins
important première étape
l'indispensable pour arriver à réduire
cette dette unification de
l'infrastructure nous ne pouvons plus
nous contenter d'un système existant
dans lequel RFF SNCF se coordonne mais
n'arrive pas à trouver un juste
équilibre économique et financier entre
les objectifs contradictoires en l'état
actuel RFF est confronté à un déficit
annuel de 1,5 milliards d'euros au titre
de la maintenance du réseau existant en
outre ils doivent également lever 1,5
milliards d'euros pour financer le
développement de quatre lignes nouvelles
que je ne cite pas ici mais que vous
avez tous en mémoire d'ici 10 ans si
nous vouons être à la hauteur des
besoins de maintenance du réseau il
faudra investir 15 milliards d'euros
c'est l'ambition du grand plan de
modernisation du réseau dans ces
conditions comment n fatisfaire d'un
système un système sous-optimal
l'unification de infrastructure au sein
de SNCF réseau constitue une évidence
qu'il était urgent de traduire dans les
faites c'est une amélioration
fondamentale dont nous espérons des
gains de productivité de mutualisation à
hauteur de 900 millions d'euros par an
d'ici 10 ans de même les fors de l'État
au titre de l'abandon des dividendes et
de l'impôt sur les sociétés devrai
soutenir SNCF réseau à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros par an ça c les efforts
con sent l'état cet équilibre financier
repose également sur la d' plan de
performance du nouvel opérateur SNCF
mobilité pour un montant de 1 milliard
l'objectif que nous poursuivons c'est la
stabilisation de la dette d'ici 10 ans
c'est un objectif on le sait ambieux nul
ne le conteste ni les établissements ni
le gouvernement il sera formalisé dans
les contrats notamment celui conclu
entre l'État et SNCF réseau dont
l'article 2 du projet de loi détaille
les clauses qui devront figurer en
particulier la trajectoire financière à
10 ans projet de loi comprend deux
gardes-fous pour éviter que SNCF réseau
ne s'écarte de la trajectoire financière
le premier gardefous c'est l'autorité de
régulation des activités ferroviaires
l'ARF ce régulateur veillera à la bonne
exécution du contrat des SNCF réseau il
émettra un avis sur le projet de budget
annuel du gestionnaire d'infrastructure
et l'incitera à le corriger s'ilil
s'écarte de la trajectoire retenue le
second gardefou c'est la règle d'or ou
règle prud ti pour le financement des
investissements de développement
c'est-à-dire l'ouverture de nouvelles
lignes qui évitera que SNCF réseau
s'endettete de manière inconsidéré si on
doit ouvrir une nouvelle ligne alors
elle sera financée par les demandeurs et
non plus par le gestionnaire de
l'infrastructure de collectivité à
l'état si elles veulent des lignes d'en
assumer le financement le respect de
cette règle d'or d'ailleurs est lui-même
surveillé par la
RF l'objectif de stabilisation de la
dette bien il s'agit est-il
réalisable les interlocuteurs que j'ai
rencontré sont restés très prudents sur
la cible visée d'ici 2025 certains ont
évoqué une stabilisation à hauteur de 60
milliards d'euros à cette date d'autres
ne se sont pas avancés pour d'autres
encore l'état ne va pas assez loin les
comptes ne seront pas équilibrés al
l'horizon 10 ans il est vrai que des
contraintes fortes pèsent sur le secteur
la commission des finances a estimé que
le scénario retenu est effectivement
soumis à des alléas le premier de ces
alléas
concerne les ressources SNCF réseau les
hausses de péage d'infrastructure fort
ces dernières années ces quat dernières
années seront limitées au moins jusqu'en
2018 SNCF réseau ne pourra donc pas
augmenter les recettes par un effet prix
quant aux subventions publiques elles
seront au mieux maintenu mais il est peu
probable qu'elles augmentent
l'environnement économique sera par
conséquent déterminant pour assurer le
dynamisme des recettes de SNCF réseau le
second aléa auquel d'ailleurs sont
soumis d'ailleurs tous les emprunteurs
et le risque d'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt il ne vous a pas échappé SNCF
réseau devra donc engager des efforts
très important sur la dépense devant la
Commission de développement durable le
président de RFF nous assurer que 10 %
de gain de productivité est un objectif
atteignable il nous a dit nous les avons
sous le pied écoutons-le et
souhaitons-le nous lui donnons donc acte
de cet engagement et nous jugerons les
résultats la commission des finances s
également demandé si nous pouvions aller
plus loin pour redonner des marges de
manœuvre àncf réseau je veux bien
évidemment parler de la question de la
reprise de toute ou partie de la dette
de l'État c'est une question qui a été
déjà posée à l'instant je ve bien
évidemment sur ce domaine vous dire que
cette idée s'appuie notamment sur le
fait que l'INC en mai dernier a
requalifié un/ers de la dette de RFF
soit environ 10 milliards d'euros de
dette publique il s'agit peut-être de la
fin d'une forme d'hypocrisie consistant
à nier le caractère public de cette
dette néanmoins il faut aussi souligner
que a reconnu qu'un actif le réseau
était inscrit face à cette dette donc
les avoirs en face des biens en
conséquence le stock de dette publique
celui qui est prise en compte pour le
calcul des ratios mastrichiens n'est pas
modifié à l'inverse si l'état venait à
reprendre cette dette il n' aurait plus
d'actifs inscrits en contrepartie et la
dette nette augmenterait à du
concurrence rendant d'autant plus
difficile l'ajustement de nos comptes
publics c'est pourquoi en l'état actuel
une telle reprise de dette ne a pas paru
souhaitable à la commission des finances
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle ne doit
pas être envisagée à terme en tout état
de cause elle n'a pas non plus paru
urgente parce que RFF reste un
emprinteur crédible les investisseurs
considèrent qu'il s'agit d'une dette de
l'État français la dette est donc peu
risquée à la différence des taux
d'intérêt entre RFF et l'État éminé et
la différence pardon d'intérêt de taux
d'intérêt entre rflétat et minime on
pourrait enfin s'interroger sur le
caractère vertueux d'une reprise de la
dette aujourd'hui le poids de la dette
est un aiguillon pour pousser SNCF
réseau à se transformer à se moderniser
elle conduira également à choisir avec
parciimonie les futurs projets de
développement je crois en effet que nous
devons nous interroger collectivement
sur les bons choix à opérés pour notre
réseau de feré national en particulier
tous les rapports d'expertise soulignent
que le réseau est trop grand et qu'il
pourrait être réduit en vue de
rationaliser l'utilisation des moyens et
de maintenir et de le maintenir dans un
état de performance acceptable
le rapport de la commission mobilité 21
l'année dernière a souligné que nous
devions faire des choix établir des
priorités dans la construction de
nouvelles infrastructures nous devons
faire les mêmes choix au regard du
réseau existant si de nouvelles
infrastructures sont nécessaires
d'autres ne le sont peut-être plus la
reprise de la dette ne doit pas occulter
ces questions fondamentales ceci étant
dit il y a également un consensus pour
dire que qu'une partie de la dette SNCF
réseau ne sera pas amortissable par le
système ferroviaire à terme à terme
l'État sera donc probablement contraint
de s'engager plus il a pour se faire
plusieurs instruments à sa disposition
la reprise de dettes mais aussi
l'augmentation des subventions le
rapport demandé à l'article 2 ter très
bien tout à l'heure expliqué notre ami
michel Teston du projet de loi doit nous
permettre d'y voir plus clair sur les
modalités de traitement de la dette
historique sous bénéfice de ces
observations la commission des finances
a émis un avis favorable aux articles
dont elle s'est saisie à savoir
l'article 1er l'article 2 de TER 4 et 5
qui comporte des dispositions qui
intéressent plus directement l'équilibre
financier de la réforme madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président et Monsieur rapporteur je
vous
remerci merci monsieur le sénateur avant
de poursuivre la discussion générale je
donne la parole à Monsieur Jean-Jacques
Fillol pour mise au point sur un vote
chers collègues vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente oui je je
voulais vous proposer au nom du groupe
socialiste une rectification au vote de
du 4 juillet au soir sur la PGL région
en effet Monsieur Roland Courteau Marcel
Renault et Jean-Noël Gorini Guerini vote
contre sur le vote final au lieu de ne
prenne pas part au vote je vous remercie
merci merci acte et donné de votre mise
au point elle sera publiée au Journal
officiel et figurera dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Louis Nigre pour le groupe UMP
chers collègues vous avez la
parole
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues enfin pourrais-je dire
enfin Monsieur le Ministre le projet que
vous nous présentez est issue d'une
lente trop lente
maturation nous savons tous depuis de
très nombreuses années que le système
ferroviaire fonctionne de moins en moins
bien il était la fierté de la France il
en devient un
souci le constat est inquiétant c'est
ainsi par exemple que malgré les plans
frêes qui se sont succédés cette
activité a diminué notablement en France
alors qu'elle progressait dans plusieurs
pays européens autre alerte dès 2005
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre le
rapport Rivier suivi en 2012 par le
rapport putalas et la Cour des comptes
nous confirm que le réseau classique
était en voie
d'effondrement autre clignotant à
l'orange qui vir au rouge le matériel
des trains d'équilibre du territoire est
obsolète et fatigué vous l'avez souligné
tout à l'heure il ne correspond plus au
service qu'il doit à sa clientèle il est
donc urgent que les nouvelles rames
arrivent sur le terrain monsieur le
ministre il n'est pas jusqu'au TGV qui
commence à son tour à avoir des
problèmes d'équilibre financier sans
oublier l'accident dramatique de
brtinie dans ce paysage
qui s'assombrit d'année en année seul
l'action déterminée des régions et leurs
investissements massifs ont apporter une
bouffée d'oxygène au ferroviair avec à
la clé une très forte augmentation des
passagers le rail continue en effet à
être un des moyens de déplacement des
plus modernes et efficaces dans cette
morosité ambiante ce dernier exemple
montre bien le rôle irremplaçable du
ferroviaire pour les transport
du quotidien monsieur le ministre la
transition énergétique et l'aménagement
du territoire c'est ce constat
aigrededou cette dégradation lente qui
m'avait amené dès octobre 2010 à
réclamer à mon gouvernement du haut de
cette tribune un Grenel du ferroviaire
il m'a fallu plus d'un an pour l'obtenir
à travers les assises du ferroviaire
aujourd'hui après des années de de
tergiversation vous nous présentez
l'aboutissement de ces discussions et
réflexions dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi portant réforme ferroviaire mon
analyse de ce texte me conduit à un
triple
constat en premier lieu je ne peux que
me féliciter que les fonctions de
gestionnaire d'infrastructure du réseau
terraé national aujourd'hui réparti
entre RFF SNCF Infra et la DCF soit
unifié cette mesure était attendue et a
fait l'unanimité auprès de tous les
acteurs elle permettra sans aucun doute
en meilleur fonctionnement du système et
une plus grande
sécurité vous redonnez à l'état grâce à
ce projet de loi un rôle d'État stratège
bienvenu pour fixer les priorités et la
cohérence du système ferroviaire j'ai
bien noter en ce sens que l'État
assurerait également le pilotage de la
filière industrielle ferroviaire dont
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
plan de charge est en diminution
dramatique à court terme de même à
travers le schéma national des des
services de transport les orientations
de l'État pourront s'afficher clairement
cette démarche s'accompagne par ailleurs
d'une mobilisation positive du Parlement
qui aura à connaître les dossiers les
plus importants du système ferroviaire
mais a priori à ma surprise sans vote
j'ai donc proposé en commission d'aller
plus loin et de voter une grande loi de
programmation
ferroviaire je pense que le Parlement
doit en débattre librement et s'engager
par un vote ainsi nous pourrons associer
toute la nation à la définition des
objectifs que doit atteindre le système
ferroviaire de même après un impère
incompréhensible dans le texte initial
vous avez accepté la vie conforme de la
RAF et vous avez même augmenté fort
justement grâce à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs ces possibilités
d'intervention dans le cadre que vous
avez choisi d'une entreprise intégrée
verticalement un régulateur fort est
absolument indispensable et j'en suis
d'accord avec le
rapporteur enfin je note avec
satisfaction que ce texte devrait
permettre de définir des objectifs de
performance et de productivité tout en
maîtrisant les dépenses à travers une
règle d'or mais j'ai également entendu
le rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances qui parlait d'or c'est le
cas de dire en disant que si tout va
bien nous ne serons qu'à 60 milliards de
dett en
2025 c'est donc un vrai problème ces
éléments positif étant acté je fais
cependant un deuxème constat qui lui m'
interpelle quant à la lisibilité du
système sa complexité telle qu'elle
apparaît à travers ce projet de loi me
plonge dans un océan de perplexité en
effet en dehors des spécialistes la
plupart des interlocuteurs que j'ai
rencontré ont eu des difficultés à
comprendre qui faisait quoi au départ
nous avons un épique mère avec deux
épiques filles dont une dispose d'une
entité autonome gare et et connexion
mais ces établissements sont à leur tour
accompagnés par une véritable nébuleuse
à travers l'existence d'un conseil de
surveillance lui-même ayant un rôle
différent du Haut Comité du système de
transport ferroviaire qui ne recouvre
pas les missions du comité des
opérateurs de réseau dont le rôle est
bien sûr différent de l'Autorité de
régulation des activités ferroviaires
qui ne doit pas se confondre avec
l'établissement public de sécurité
ferroviaire sans compter monsieur le
ministre la commission des sanctions la
commission de déontologie et le Haut
Comité à la qualité de service dans les
transports qui tous concourent à des
degrés divers au fonctionnement du
système ferroviaire français dans le
système précédent après des années on ne
savait toujours pas à qui appartenaient
les quai et à qui appartenaient les
bordure de qu le système actuel n'est
malheureusement pas plus lisible cette
organisation qui ressemble fort à une
usine agace est difficilement
compréhensible pour le commun des
mortels
malheureusement monsieur le ministre je
fais un troisième constat qui lui est
beaucoup plus grave en effet il y a
toute une série de points sur lesquels
je ne partage pas votre philosophie et
votre vision de l'avenir je me situe
même à l'opposé
de votre démarche politique et vous n'en
serez pas
étonné j'en veux pour preuve plusieurs
éléments avec deux séries de réaction de
plus en plus négatives de ma part une
première série de désaccords porte
notamment sur trois points et
oui et oui oui et ben oui mais je suis
un sénateur libre et honnête je dis ce
que je pense et donc j'annonce j'annonce
toute série de choses que je trouve
positives et je dis aussi ce qui ne me
paraît pas positif voilà et c'est
l'honneur de la Haute Assemblée de
pouvoir parler ainsi sur le commissaire
du Gouvernement auprès de la RAF
l'utilité de ce dernier m'échappe en
effet le gouvernement peut très bien
transmettre ses analyses directement à
l'ARAF sans avoir besoin d'un
commissaire qui fait penser plutôt à un
commissaire politique nous nous sentons
d'autant plus en droit
nous nous sentons monsieur le ministre à
droite nous nous sentons d'autant plus
en droit de faire cette remarque que
dans le cadre de l'arcepep de l'Autorité
de régulation des communications
électroniques et des postes en 2011
cette même manie couverlemental avait
été retoqué par la Commission
européenne concernant deè point
concernant d'autre part la gestion des
gares le rapport du 22 avril
2013 de Jacques hoxiet bien connu sur
tous ses bans à gauche avait préconisé
de regrouper au sein de SNCF réseau
l'ensemble du patrimoine foncier
ferroviaire cela paraissait on ne peut
plus logique dans le même sens
l'Autorité de la concurrence dans son
avis du 4 octobre 2013 juge elle aussi
nécessaire que soit garanti la
neutralité concurrentielle des gares de
voyageurs pour dit-elle ne pas entraver
un développement effectif de la
concurrence cet avis ne souffre pas
d'interprétation il est très clair et je
ne peux donc monsieur le ministre que
regretter votre position enfin
concernant les matériels roulants
régionaux je suis monsieur le ministre
là encore en totale opposition avec
votre article 5 bis du projet de loi en
effet il est incompréhensible pour tout
être normalement constitué que les rég
qui ont financé avec les deniers publics
des contribuables locaux l'intégralité
des rames n'en soit pas propriétaire et
j'avoue que dans le cadre de la
commission du développement durable
grâce au président et à son rapporteur
nous avançons nous cheminons vers
peut-être une solution qui nous
paraissait plus logique je me pose la
question de savoir Monsieur le Ministre
pourquoi vous avez inscrit cette mesure
aussi étrange qui logique mais mais s'il
n'y avait que ces
remarques hélas trois fois hélas il y a
encore plus grave il s'agit à mes yeux
de trois points fondamentaux qui ne sont
pas traités
ou mieux tout juste aborder le premier
point porte sur la dette de la vie
générale la situation est gravissime
aujourd'hui elle explose à plus de 40
milliards d'euros elle entraîne une
charge financière de près de 1 milliard
et demi
ce problème essentiel dans le cadre
d'une vraie réforme ferroviaire ne fait
l'objet que d'approches qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur du problème il est
significatif que le gouvernement n'est
prévu chers collègues n'est prévu qu'un
simple rapport sur les solutions qui
pourrai au conditionnel être mise en
œuvre et ceci dans 2 ans cette situation
est ancienne et chaque année un peu plus
alarmante votre proposition i à la
différence des mesures drastiques et
douloureuses compris les Allemands en
leur temps consiste à repousser à plus
tard l'assaainissement des comptes c'est
d'autant plus incompréhensible
qu'eurostat Linse et la Cours des
comptes ont confirmé qu'il était dès
aujourd'hui possible de transférer plus
de 10 milliards à l'état ce qui
permettrait en 2 ans chers collègues de
soulager le système ferroviaire d'un
milliard d'euros de charge de la dette
alors qu'il y a le feu à la maison on
regarde ailleurs et ce problème
gravissime plombe l'ensemble du système
ferroviaire et je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'avis de la commission des finances la
commission numéro 3 desassises auquel je
vous renvoie a d'ailleurs confirmé cette
analyse en son temps en précisant que la
seule la seule clé de désendettement du
secteur était la raison du déficit
structurel nous en sommes
loin ce qui nous amène un deuxème point
fondamental de votre réforme qui est
l'absence je dis bien l'absence
d'ouverture à la
concurrence en 2009 chers collègues mon
premier amendement sénatorial déposé à
la haute assemblée était consacré à une
ouverture maîtrisée à la
concurrence je crois profondément quant
à moi que ce mécanisme s'avèerait
extrêmement bénéfique pour la SNCF et
pour les usagers mais au lieu d'aborder
franchement cette question et de passer
à l'offensive nous reculons à nouveau en
effet en effet la commission numéro 1
des Assises du ferroviaire présidée par
Monsieur Gilles Savari qui n'était pas
encore rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale avait déclaré en 2011 il y a 4
ans déjà que le principe d'une ouverture
à la concurrence était acté pour les
autorités organisatrices qui le
souhaiteraient malheureusement en 2014
il n'en a toujours rien bien au
contraire le texte n'en parle même pas à
l'image de l'urbain la concurrence
instaurée je vous le rappelle par Michel
Sapin en personne permet
pourtant le développement et permettrait
pourtant le développement de l'emploi au
sein de la SNCF d'ug l'offre pour les
usagers et enfin de réaliser des
économies substantielles de l'ordre de
15 à 20 % ce qui est considérable les
870 millions d'euros annuels ainsi
économisés permettrait soit des
investissements supplémentaires soit de
diminuer la charge financière des
collectivités et donc des contribuables
c'est d'autant plus regrettable que la
SNCF libéré à l'international est tout à
fait capable de conquérir vous l'avez
dit sans aucun dumping social des part
de marcher et de promouvoir avec une
grande efficacité la marque
France enfin le dernier point qui
s'inscrit dans la logique qui est la
vôtre et que je récuse totalement va
entraîner le verrouillage complet du
système ferroviaire national à travers
le caractère indissociable et solidaire
des trois entités à travers la création
d'un seul comité central du groupe
public à travers un délégué syndical
central à travers toutes ces
dispositions de dernièrees minute qui
fleur bon le centralisme démocratique
nous en revenons à la SNCF de
grandpa c'est un retour en arrière
complet si l'on ajoute l'intangibilité
des statuts et leur inadaptation en
monde qui évolue si l'on ajoute que le
décret socle fera disparaître le peu de
concurrence qui existait on aboutit
encore une fois au syndrome de la ligne
maginau rester autant sur la défensive
s'enfermer sur les droits acquis en bref
ne pas bouger ne pas évoluer entraînera
malheureusement un affaiblissement du
système ferroviaire susceptible à terme
de mettre en cause son existence même
votre modèle pour reprendre votre terme
monsieur le ministre n'est pas notre
modèle le cas dramatique de la SNCM
devrait pourtant nous alerter sur la
nécessité pour la France de développer
des entreprises compétitives aptes à
gagner la bataille de l'emploi plutôt
qu'à se recroqueevier sur elle-même en
définitive monsieur le ministre votre
projet de loi se limite à une réforme
institutionnelle il ne touche pas et ne
traite donc pas au fond les problèmes
principaux j'insiste qui grèvent
l'avenir du rail comparaison n'est pas
raison mais après l'exemple allemand je
peux aussi prendre l'exemple italien
actuel où le président du Conseil
Matthéo renzy lance une réforme
structurelle par mois c'est l'opposé de
cette approche et détriqué de ce manque
de
vision cette réforme n'engage pas les
réformes de structure madame la
Présidente absolument indispensable elle
n'est pas la loi fondatrice du
ferroviaire attendue depuis 2011 c'est
donc une mini réforme suivi à
l'Assemblée nationale d'une
contre-réforme et cet exemple nous amène
à un texte baroque qui n'est absolument
pas à la hauteur des enjeux en
conséquence le groupe UMP votera contre
ce projet de loi merci Monsieur le sénur
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent cap
canas pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur sénateur vousz la parole etè
écout madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président de la Commission de
développement durable messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
système ferroviaire français est
constitutif de notre identité il fait je
ne parle pas au passé la fierté de notre
pays malgré les difficultés la fierté
des cheminaux d'abord fierté légitime et
celle de nos compatriotes nous aimons
les chemins de fer pour autant nous
devons donner un nouveau départ au
modèle ferroviaire français
ce modèle ferroviaire c'est une vision
de la France de la mobilité des
territoires on sait que combien cela
compte en particulier ici au Sénat la
SNCF dans l'histoire nous a montré
combien elle savait être au rendez-vous
nous devons nous aussi être rendez-vous
pour franchir une étape indispensable au
renouveau du chemin de fer français nous
mesurons l'enjeu permettre au système
fERRIA français d'assurer son avenir
l'enjeu c'est à partir de cette histoire
de cette tradition française avec les
cheminaux de redonner au système
ferroviaire français un cadre clair qui
lui permet de se développer pour
perpétuer cette tradition la renouveler
il faut changer changer car la situation
actuelle ne peut durer changer car les
cheminaux eux-mêmes appellent à plus
d'efficacité il faut redonner au système
ferroviaire français une ambition non
pas qu'il en manque aujourd'hui mais la
question posée est celle des moyens je
crois que le système ferroviaire
français est un tournant ce moment est
sans doute un moment clé il faut changer
certes changer pour mieux de faire
fovière au départ il y a plusieurs
constats la complexité du système actuel
le besoin de modernisation du réseau
l'impasse financierre qui
malheureusement va
croissant une question aussi celle de la
hiérarchisation des priorités quel
réseau comment
l'entretenir face à ces constats notre
ambition est de renouveler le système
ferroviaire
français il est bon que l'État se dote
enfin d'une stratégie en matière
ferroviaire il est inutile de développer
plus longuement les mots de notre
système car cela a été dit par de
nombreux orateurs et encore à l'instant
par Louis negre la spirale de
l'endettement un réseau vieillissant et
dégradé dans de danst de multiples
rapports ont fait le constat et bien
évidemment nous avons une pensée pour
les victimes de l'accident de brtinie au
moment où le rapport vient d'être publié
un système pas assez compétitif aussi
c'est une réalité qu'il faut voir en
face avec un coût supérieur de 30 % à
celui de nos voisins et aujourd'hui
urrencé par d'autres modes de transport
le projet de loi élaboré par le
gouvernement avec les acteurs du
ferroviaire je le dis dans cet ordre
sans malice croyant ne pas vous tromper
ce projet de loi gouvernemental donc
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la réflexion
lancée par le précédent gouvernement au
travers des Assises du ferroviaire il y
a une forme de continuité au moins dans
l'intention de départ l'équation de
départ est simple les intentions étaient
claires reconstituer un gestionnaire
unifié
d'infrastructure cela faisait fait
toujours
consensus mais aussi adapter le système
ferroviaire français aux exigences
d'aujourd'hui et ça c'est plus
douloureux ça l'était au départ ça le
sera toujours et les grèves récentes ont
montré l'inquiétude des cheminaux et la
difficulté de la tâche parmi les
exigences d'aujourd'hui auxquelles il
faut savoir s'adapter je voudrais citer
C axes de travail la qualité de service
aux voyageurs nous la devons aux usagers
elle existe elle doit s'améliorer pour
plus de régularité la sécurité chacun le
mesure avec force évidemment à quelques
jours de l'anniversaire de la
catastrophe de brtinie parce qu'il faut
voir les choses en face aussi le coûte
du système ferroviaire aujourd'hui trop
élevé est aussi une exigence qu'il faut
relever la nécessaire inclusion des
chemins de fer dans une stratégie
globale de mobilité avec la concurrence
et la complémentarité des autres modes
de transport s'impose également à nous
enfin la concurrence mot tabou mais
réalité de demain à laquelle nous
devrons nous conforter pour en ressortir
vainqueur doit être regardé en face ni
la perspective n'est pas la solution
face à ces différents enjeux le projet
lois soumis à la Haute Assemblée souffre
selon nous de trois insuffisances en
premier lieu le système mis en place est
complexe avec trois épiques imbriquet
l'heureux compatibilité que vous
revendiquez restera à confirmer avec la
nouvelle Commission nouveau Parlement
européen attention à l'adoption du 4e
paquet quelques points majeurs restent à
signaler l'accès équitable au réseau le
rôle du régulateur la place
prépondérante de l'opérateur historique
l'andogamie du système dans la version
initiale du texte resta des questions
assez maltraité et demeure encore à
améliorer en second lieu votre réforme
me paraît insuffisamment financé elle ne
traite pas assez de la dette ferroviaire
qui atteint 44 milliards d'euros qui
progresse d' Milard 5 par an devrait
atteindre 60 milliards dans quelques
années et 70 milliards en 2025 une
réforme sans la dette est-ce une réforme
enfin le projet de loi se concentrant
essentiellement sur les questions de
gouvernance il contourne la question
principale de la modernisation du
système ferroviaire de l'amélioration de
la qualité de service de la productivité
et de l'adaptation à la concurrence
cette réalité est pourtant devant nous
cela étant dit le travail de l'Assemblée
nationale a permis des avancés un
premier pas a été fait en direction des
régions pas trop timide avec plus de
transparence des comptes une liberté
tarifaire à peine esquissée la question
du matériel roulant abordé
imparfaitement mais abordé le chef de
Filat pour les gares d'intérêt régional
je crois que les régions seront les
moteurs de la rénovation du système
elles n'en ont pas encore les moyens un
premier pas a été fait en leur direction
ce pas est selon nous beaucoup trop
timide la seule avancée notable concerne
la transparence des comptes des Lig TER
que réclam légitimement les régions le
chef de fila qui leur été reconnu
uniquement pour les gardes d'intérêts
régional et la question du matériel
roulant ne me paraît pas suffisamment
bien
réglé des améliorations ont été
apportées sur la gouvernance et les
pouvoirs de Laaraf le régulateur ce
point mérite lui aussi d'être renforcé
nous estimons que ces améliorations sont
encore insuffisantes et qu'il faut
encore renforcer l'étanchéité entre les
différents épiques et garantir
l'indépendance de l'autorité de
régulation afin de garantir la la non
discrimination entre
opérateurs s'agissant de la dette la
règle prudentielle a été seulement
esquissée et en aucun cas les économies
d'échelle attendu ne permettront de
réduire le stock de dette ce point est
majeur les promesses économies sont pas
des économies et il en est ici comme du
budget de l'État malheureusement le
cadre social a été complété
certes pour rassurer les cheminaux qui
doivent accompagner la réforme et en
être acteurs être de véritables acteurs
du changement ces avancées i de la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale on
pourrait les résumer en deux temps une
part de réalisme les régions laarf il
s'agit de premier pas à conforter une
part de dialogue social renforcé gageons
que le cadre social amélioré sera demain
un élément positif et pas un élément de
blocage du moins souhaitons-le cette
réforme peut encore être améliorée il y
a et j'ai entendu Louis negre à
l'instant deux attitudes possibles
condamner la réforme mais n'est-ce pas
condamner le système ferroviaire a-t-on
le temps ou bien faire le pari du
pragmatisme et construire pas à pas mais
en accélérant donc choisir d'améliorer
le texte nous choisirions volontiers le
pragmatisme s'il était réciproque je
crois que faire de ce sujet un combat
idéologique ce ne serait pas un service
à rendre système ferroviaire il y a des
réalités et des
urgences la réforme telle qu'elle est
proposée aujourd'hui malgré les travaux
de la commission et je salue le
président Val le rapporteur michel
Teston cette réforme est largement
imparfaite notre volonté de regarder
comment l'approfondir en allant plus
loin dans l'adaptation au 4e paquet
ferroviaire en préparant progressivement
l'ouverture à la concurrence ici il me
faut m'adresser à vous monsieur le
ministre il y a une ambigué dans votre
réforme et vous devez la lever soit
c'est la politique de l'autruche et nous
connaîtrons pour le trafic voyageur ce
que nous avons avons connu pour le fret
soit c'est un pas pour adapter
réellement le système ferroviaire aux
réalité
d'aujourd'hui si comme je le souhaite la
deuxième hypothèse est la bonne vous
devez accepter ici de faire bouger les
curseurs j'entends bien que le cadre
social doit être
respecté je comprends que l'architecture
institutionnelle du projet peut
difficilement à ce stade
évoluer considérablement mais je dois
ici rappeler que autant nous sommes
d'accord avec la constitution d'un
gestionnaire d'infrastructure
unifié c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
conclusions des Assises du ferroviaire
et on peut estimer ici que la réforme de
97 a montré ses limites mais autant nous
sommes d'accord avec le Guu autant le
pôle public intégré nous laisse
dubitatif mais sur les autres point sur
l'économie sur le régulateur sur la
dette sur le pouvoir des régions il faut
je crois savoir aller plus loin franchir
le pas qui fera cette réforme une
adaptation nécessaire et utile plutôt
qu'un élément qui est destiné à éviter
de voir les réalités notre guide dans la
tion des articles et des amendements
sera simple nous amenderons sur des
points précis certains d'ailleurs ont
été évoqué par louisegre parce que nous
avons un certain nombre d'axes
évidemment commun nous poursuivrons
plusieurs objectifs je voudrais en
rappeler C
rapidement le premier c'est d'inscrire
la stabilisation voir la diminution de
la dette comme priorité de cette réforme
ferroviaire encore une fois une réforme
sans la dette s repoussée à demain le
plus important
le deuxème objectif c'est de
préparer le système ferroviaire au 4e
paquet et à l'ouverture à la concurrence
en permettant par exemple aux régions
d'expérimenter les délégations de
service public il peut y avoir plusieurs
façons d'y arriver mais l'intention le
réalisme doiv être là le trème objectif
doit être de renforcer l'indépendance
des établissements publics au sein du
pôle unifié que vous avez choisie afin
de rendre le projet de loi pleinement
compatible avec les règles européennes
c'est aussi d'ailleurs ncessaire pour
garantir un accès équitable au réseau
notre 4ème objectif en concordance avec
le précédent c'est bien sûr de renforcer
encore les pouvoirs de la RAF comme
véritable autorité de régulation
indépendante et louisgre a évoqué tout à
l'heure la question du commissaire du
gouvernement c'est d'autant plus
nécessaire que votre système peut
parfois être considéré comme ambigu donc
remettons de la clarté enfin nous
voulons c'est le 5è objectif rendre le
train plus compétitif et plus att actif
cela veut dire améliorer la productivité
du système la qualité du service rendu
aux usagers revenir à des prix
concurrentiels aussi quand même quand on
est sur Internet et qu'on regarde les
prix on se désespère parfois tout cela
appelle une volonté claire sur les
points que je viens d'énumérer je veux
dire que la réponse du gouvernement sera
déterminante pour que nous considérions
notre vote nous avons déposé des
amendements et nous aurons l'occasion
d'approfondir la discussion votre projet
de départ n'est pas le notre monsieur le
ministre vous le savez l'assemblée l'a
amélioré il reste du chemin à faire sur
le texte initial nous avions de grandes
réserve une partie a été levée nous
mesurons l'enjeu pour le système
ferroviaire et les chemineaux l'enjeu
c'est de s'adapter et de se redonner les
moyens d'être
compétitif repousser la mise en
concurrence sans s'y préparer n'est pas
la solution au contraire c'est
l'assurance de réveil douloureux ce
texte s'il est adopté par le Sénat ce
qui ne me paraît pas acquis à cette
heure ne règlera pas tout il faudra
demain encore aller plus loin dans
l'expérimentation des délégations de
service public gageons que les régions
elles-mêmes y
viendront après tout le droit européen
existe il faudra aussi à court terme
réussir le 4e paquet ferroviaire avec un
parle européen et une commission
renouvelée ce ne sera pas forcément le
plus facile la France a trop souvent
l'image d'un pays qui ne sait pas se
réformer si cette réforme devra bien sûr
être suivie d'autres dans ce domaine
précis elle peut malgré tout contribuer
à améliorer la situation du chemin de
fer français la discussion vaut en tout
cas d'être engagé et c'est dans cet
esprit que nous examinerons ce texte je
terminerai en évoquant bien sûr les
attentes des voyageurs il est des
secteurs et l'Île-de-France en est un
vous le savez monsieur le ministre où
l'exaspération des voyageurs est à son
comble hier encore monsieur le ministre
le RB ici à la station Luxembourg était
bloqué à 20h en plein conseil municipal
j'attendais encore un C nom de mes élus
qui étaient là encore dans la er r il
faut répondre à cette attente je cite la
ligne que je connais le mieux mais il y
en a d'autres qui souffrent tout autant
je peux dire aussi que les annonces du
procureur d'v
forcément légitime quant à l'état de vé
du réseau en particulier en Gard de
noisilse interroge et interpelle nos
concitoyens il faut monsieur le ministre
rassurer sur les moyens mis en œuvre car
les usagers et le maire de noisils en
particulier sont légitimement inquiets
du constat qui a été livré à l'opinion
tout cela nous rappelle si besoin que la
finalité du réseau comme du transporteur
c'est bien d'être au service du public
pour trans transorter chacun des usagers
en cela le système ferroviaire répond à
une obligation de service public et
d'égalité c'est un beau défi qu'il nous
faut relever aujourd'hui encore alors je
sais la passion du ferroviaire et le
talent de notre rapporteur michel Teston
je sais Monsieur ministre votre écoute
du Parlement et je veux dire que dans la
discussion qui
s'engage on aura quelques idées simples
en tête cette réforme était assez mal
engagée peut-être sur la mauvaise voix à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a peut-être
failli dérailler avec la grève vous avez
réussi à ce qu'il n'en soit rien après
son passage à l'assemblée a été
rééguillée dans un sens plus favorable
espérons qu'avec son examen au Sénat
elle sera enfin sur de bons rail il
n'appartient qu'à vous monsieur le
ministre d'orienter ce projet de loi
dans le bon sens et de faire arriver
cette réforme à qu et à temps je vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur la
parole est maintenant à Madame churche
pour le groupe
CRC chers collègues vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers
collègues maintenance inadaptée
délabrement jamais vu les mots du
procureur en charge de l'accident de
breken sont dures très dures à entendre
pour nous qui aimons le chemin de fer
ils font cependant écho à ceux des
chemineau qui depuis plusieurs années
nous alertent sur la dégradation du
service public ferroviaire ainsi que du
constat unanimement partagé des Assises
du ferroviaire cela vient s'ajouter
aussi à la charge médiatique sur les
rames de de TER inadapté à la largeur
des quais et renforce le sentiment de
gâchie et d'insécurité des usagers la
SNCF est une entreprise publique de
servicees public caractérisé par
certaines valeurs qui cimentent le corps
social et le territoire national
malheureusement les choix des
gouvernement successif et de la
Direction ont tendu à l'assimiler à une
entreprise comme une autre le
cloisonnement des métiers et des
personnels ainsi que le recours massif à
la sous-traitance des activités
essentielles met à mal la
complémentarité et les savoirs multiples
apportant son lot d'inquiétude de
souffrance et de
dysfonctionnement pour notre part dans
une démarche constante et cohérente nous
n'avons jamais cessé de pointer les
lacunes de la réforme de 97 le poids des
intérêts divergents de RFF et
SNCF la perte d'énergie dans la gestion
des relations entre deux entreprises
publiques qui devaient logiquement
travailler ensemble et la remise en
cause de la légitimité des chemineaux
que ce soit dans notre proposition de
loi permettant la relance du secteur
public ferroviaire de mai 2012 ou encore
notre proposition de résolution tendant
à la maîtrise publique du système
ferroviaire nationale de juillet 2013
sans parler de notre résolution
demandant une évaluation de la
libéralisation du secteur nous avons été
attentifs aux préoccupations des acteurs
de terrain et appelé de nos vœux une
réforme du système ferroviaire c'est
pourquoi nous saluons monsieur le
ministre vos efforts pour que ce texte
soit inscrit à l'ordre du jour de nos
assemblées cela d'autant plus qu'une
course de vitesse est engagée avec la
Commission européenne toutefois le 4e
paquet ferroviaire vous l'avez rappelé
n'est pas encore voté et la Commission
européenne a déjà dû reculer à cet égard
rappelons que le droit positif impose
seulement une séparation des fonctions
essentielles la définition des péages et
la répartition des S de plus les États
et donc les gouvernements ne sont pas
étrangers à la production législative
européenne et ils ont une marge de
manœuvre dans la transposition des
directives c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre n'utilisez pas l'argument de
l'euro compatibilité ou de la
concurrence comme
indépassable il ne peut pas y avoir de
double discours un national et l'autre
européen votre gouvernement monsieur le
ministre veut je l'ai entendu de la part
du Premier ministre un gouvernement de
combat et la France vous l'avez rappelé
je reprends vos mots et une grande
nation ferroviaire et européenne qui a
un poids certain dans les négociations
européennes ce projet de loi est donc
une formidable opportunité pour faire
valoir les exigences de la France dans
le domaine
ferroviaire dès lors pardon ne
reproduisons pas les erreurs passées
scouvert d'un discours d'urgence ou de
contraintte réell et ou imaginaire c'est
pourquoi nous porterons à travers nos
amendements la défense d'un modèle un
ifié autour de l'entreprise publique
SNCF car il a fait ses preuves par le
passé et nous pensons qu'il est seul à
même de répondre aux défis du futur aux
exigences d'un service public
ferroviaire fiable et performant au
services des usagers et des territoires
un service public qui ne soit pas comme
cela transparaît en filigran dans ce
projet de loi exclusivement orienté vers
la gestion de
l'infrastructure le service public que
nous fendon englobe l'offre de service
la gestion et le déploiement des réseaux
mais aussi la gestion des gares et du
patrimoine ferroviaire s'il est
impératif de mettre un terme à l'absence
de vision cohérente à long terme du
système ferroviaire la question de son
financement ne peut être minoré et
reporté dans le temps à sa création RFF
a hérité de la dette SNCF au départ 20
milliards d'euros qui devient
aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé le
rapporteur colossal qui n'apparaît plus
comme de la dette publique pourtant le
désentêement de la SNCF aurait pu être
obtenu par le transfert d'une partie de
ces dettes de à l'état ce que la
directive de 91 autorisait d'ailleurs
dans la plupart des autres pays
européens l'État a ainsi repris une
grande partie des dettes de l'opérateur
ferroviaire historique comme en
Allemagne par exemple pourtant force de
constater que l'État n'a toujours pas
l'INT tion de désentêter le système
ferroviaire ce projet à notre avis
n'apporte pas de réponse satisfaisante à
cette question pourtant
cruciale la seule perspective de ce
projet de loi sur le financement du
système réside dans ce que vous appelez
des gains de performance dans les
organisations et les modes de travail
dans l'ensemble du groupe et
l'optimisation de l'offre ferroviaire
vous comprendrez monsieur le ministre
qu'au vu de l'actualité cela crée un
certain malaise
car c'est cette logique d'abaissement
des coûts de suppression d'emploi
d'abaissement de la qualité des
formations dispensées de réduction des
moyens financiers et matériels qui
dégradent les conditions de travail des
cheminaux et la qualité du service
public SNCF rendu aux usagers et à la
nation cette logique qui encourage un
recours toujours plus important à la
sous-traitance pour réaliser la
maintenance verra peut-être se
multiplier la catastrophe comme celle de
brtinie car selon les chiffres annoncés
lors des débats à l'Assemblée nationale
pour trouver 250 millions d'euros
annuels il faudrait réduire les
effectifs de
4330 personnes par an en 5 ans ce serait
donc plus de 20000 salariés en moins
reconnaissons monsieur le ministre les
craintes des cheminaux ne sont pas dénué
de
fondement de plus quand vous parlez de
l'op optimisation de l'offre ferroviaire
ainsi que la règle prudentielle il
prévoit une hiérarchisation des
investissements en faveur des projets
présentant le meilleur retour
d'investissement ce qui à terme se
traduira
inévitablement par des fermetures de
lignes en effet le projet prévoit un
système de priorisation des projets
ferroviaires c'est-à-dire que les
travaux nécessaires à la régénération du
réseau ne seraient effectués que
lorsqu'ils sont juget utile et que les
finances le permettent c'est-à-dire pour
certaines de ces lignes jamais c'est
donc le passage de la recherche d'une
sécurité maximale un risque calculé il
faudra expliquer cela à nos concitoyens
monsieur le ministre vous rayez au fond
d'un trait de plume les engagements de
la commission mobilité
21 d'autre part la gestion en temps réel
du trafic relève complètement de
l'opérationnel de l'exploitation FERR
oviaire et fait partie des fondements de
la sécurité de la qualité des services
ferroviaires effectifs alors que la
gestion de l'infrastructure au sens
propre a lieu en amont en temps différé
où est donc dans votre projet la
construction d'une synergie en temps
réel des équipes de terrain par exemple
aiguillage et manœuvre de train sur ce
terrain monsieur le ministre votre
réforme ne ne répond pas aux attentes
des cheminaux en terme
d'efficacité à cet égard le nouveau rôle
de gendarme financier d'évolu à Laaraf
nous interroge nous avons toujours
contester vous le savez ce type de
structure dont les missions n'ont à
notre avis rien à voir avec le service
public puisque l'unique objectif
poursuivi et de faire de la place aux
nouveaux entrants et donc d'assurer la
concurrence nous portons l'idée que la
régulation du système ferroviaire
régulation oui du système ferroviaire
doit être la mission de l'État plutôt
que d'une structure soi-disant
indépendante et loin de la notion de
service public eurocompatibilité
ouverture à la concurrence pérennité de
la réforme mais aussi unicité du système
sont les termes que vous utiliser pour
décrire votre réforme vous nous dites
efficacité du système ainsi pour
remédier à l'éclatement du passé il
faudrait la création de nouvelles
entités vous en avez cré 3 en SNCF SNCF
réseau et SNCF
mobilité par une une une mathématique
pardon opaque vous affirmez monsieur le
ministre que tris seraient plus
performant que 2 et que trois seraiit
encore plus performant que un pourtant
les directives européennes n'imposent
absolument pas la mise en place de trois
épiques distinctes elle n'exige de
séparation organique que pour les
fonctions essentielles pourquoi ne pas
avoir simplement externaliser ses
fonctions auprès de la DG ITM et
reconstruit un groupe public ferroviaire
autour d'un seul épic si l'objectif est
la rationalisation et l'efficacité du
système pourquoi n'avoir pas reenu cette
solution de bon sens au lieu de
multiplier les structures et compétences
de coordination d'arbitrage de
consultation d'autant qu'il y a toujours
un président de SNC SNCF réseau un
président de SNCF mobilité la complexité
est loin à notre avis d'avoir disparu
vous nous dites que cette réforme
apportera des économies pouvez-vous être
plus précis au vu de l'empilement de
toutes ces nouvelles structures et
instances diverses et varié vous nous
dites pérennité de la réforme ce choix
des trois épiques nous interroge en
effet et vous le savez l'pque est une
forme juridique aujourd'hui menacée la
Cour de justice de l'Union Union
Européenne a une suspicion sur le régime
juridique des épiques à cet égard
l'exemple de la Poste est éclairant et
nous nous sommes battus à gauche contre
le changement de statut de La Poste à
l'époque il ne faudrait donc qu'un pas
pour que la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne juge tout simplement les épis
comme incompatibles avec le marché
intérieur
prenez du recul